the contours of your awareness
are much clearer now the knot in your
mind
is beginning to unwind you are drowning
in the here and now
i think i'm starting to get the hang of
all this inner harmony is like coming
home from a long journey
do not cling too tightly to your
thoughts
but allow them to flow freely does a
toad
clench its fist when it swims what is
the sound of one hand
clapping that depends is someone
clapping with you i want to try another
one
how much would you like to pay this time
will this be enough yes
you may begin i will guide you
[Music]
spirit of fire spirit of the sun
i send you greetings you give beauty to
all
other things i am you
and you are me there is no life without
you
from you i was created and to you i will
return
spirit of the sun primordial fire
burn all impurity from my body and soul
and the negative energy of negative
people
worlds and dimensions
cleanse every cell of my body
give me the energy of life health
youth wisdom knowledge
strength joy and happiness
give me lasting inner peace so that no
one may shake me
from my sacred equilibrium
through half closed eyes we absorb the
sun's divine
energy through our eyes
the energy of fire of the sun touches
our heads
and flows down through every organ until
it arrives
at our toes
each and every cell within our body
including the subtle and etheric
is replenished with the sun's energy
and from within us light
emerges
we are the sun
we thank you spirit of the sun element
of fire
with our mind body and soul
of course that would happen